it's great to welcome to the program
today David Charmin who's the owner and
general manager of just the cheese our
audience of course can get 20% off just
the cheese products using the URL and
coupon code in the video description
David it's great to have you on thank
you David pleasure to be here so I mean
let's just start with one of the most
obvious things that has happened in
American and really global society over
the last few months there's been a huge
increase in the amount of food people
are buying at supermarkets and there's
been a huge decrease in the amount of
food that people are buying at
restaurants and although it might seem
simple enough that the trucks can just
bring the food to the grocery stores
instead of to the restaurants it's
really not quite so simple is it no
unfortunately it's not you know you have
two different supply chains and two very
different types of end-users so for
instance a food service can of tomato
sauce probably won't fit in most
household pantries it's that big it's a
couple of gallons foodservice chicken is
not does not come and nice easy clean
one-pound trays it comes in boxes of 10
pounds so changing from not only a
production standpoint there's hey the
producers themselves have to change how
to calibrate how much demand for chicken
is there is that going up or down the
processors well what parts of the
chicken should I sell how do I package
it do I have the packaging capability to
do that and then the distributors the
folks that take product to foodservice
locations are typically not the same as
the people who take it to grocery stores
so you've got all sorts of different
things that are wildly in flux at the
moment and is that why for example you
know if Italian restaurants all of a
sudden closed you'd imagine that there's
plenty of pasta available for your
grocery store shelves but for months you
were seeing empty groceries
or shelves when it came to pasta limits
on the amount you can purchase so it's
not just the the food product itself but
it seems like it's the packaging as well
that's exactly right and for pasta
specifically it's not only hey we these
giant company who were a small business
but you know giant companies that make
your traditional spaghetti z' they've
planned their production their inventory
levels at their retailers at their
distributors months and years in advance
and so changing that all of a sudden
when a usual family might buy a couple
of packages a week at most is now buying
ten they sort of caught the entire
system off guard and it's not a quick
reaction industry it's very much a oh my
god how are we gonna possibly do this so
let's look at maybe we can talk through
an example that applies to just the
cheese and and the product you're
involved in so can you give us a sense
of like how long is the total process in
terms of so cheese products are made
from milk and milk comes from cows and
the milk has to be transported but
you've got to get the milk from the cows
and you don't you know that you only get
milk from certain cows so if you wanted
to for example double your production
how far down do the dominoes go before
you would be able to do that so great
question and it sort of varies
case-by-case so and it also depends on
it the timeline of when you ask me this
so if we were having this conversation
in late March or early April the farmers
who supply us our milk were begging us
to take more because food service went
away schools went away
Starbucks closed all of this fluid milk
demand from bottlers or ice cream makers
all just disappeared overnight and with
that glut of milk prices are in the tank
and I could I could buy as much milk as
I could possibly store in mine
but storage and processing speed is part
of the problem that I physically can
only take in about 3 ish million pounds
of fluid milk per week so if I want to
make more than use more than that I
either have to produce faster or build
more storage and that's not a quick
thing and we're pretty much running full
capacity three shifts right now okay so
that was going to be my question which
is one way would be to explore how to
store more milk and that could take some
time maybe you could lease space rather
than build spammin there's different
options in terms of capacity to produce
if you're already running three shifts
you can't really do much more can you
yeah and so we have two parts of our
business I run our baked cheese the just
the cheese operation my dad and I run
the fresh cheese business together and
the fresh cheese side runs 24/7 6 days a
week and the baked cheese side we run a
full one shift with overtime if we need
it so if demand exploded there again
we're a small business we're more agile
than most and we're growing so we have
that capacity but we would still run
into the bottleneck of I physically
can't make the cheese to put into the
oven to bake sort blood from a stone at
a certain point when it comes to the
economics as affected by dealing with
perishable versus non or less perishable
raw materials from what I've been
reading preparing for our interview
something like apples sometimes when you
get apples at the grocery store those
are apples that may have been on a tree
not that long ago but sometimes they
could be apples that are actually from
like the previous November for example
if they're picked at the right time and
stored in the right way apples can
actually last seven eight months or
something like that when it comes to
milk which III mean it's it's perishable
but then you've also got shelf-stable
milk although I don't know if that would
make the cheese products that you're
trying to make I don't know the answer
to that you're also affected by the fact
that at some point the milk is going to
go bad right
yeah and that's a big driver in
agricultural economics it's
perishability
of inventory so for fresh milk to make
cheese
I need class three raw milk and then
once I get it to my facility I basically
can keep it in a silo for a day or two
tops it's re a day or two before I have
to run it through my pasteurizer kill
all the bugs inside of it and then make
cheese okay so I can you a altra high
temperature milk the shelf-stable stuff
same basic rule but instead of
pasteurizing it at a certain temperature
that makes it
FDA approved to make cheese I have to
heat it up for longer and hotter to kill
all the bacteria and then package it in
a sterile package so it can withstand
being it can be shelf stable but because
you cook it so long and so hot you kill
all the active cultures bacteria
ingredients that make cheese making
possible so that's not the right milk to
make cheese from right but it's an
excellent example of hey you can make
UHT milk like look a bottling plant
theoretically you could say well instead
of just making the traditional
pasteurized homogenized gallons you see
everywhere well you could just make it
shelf stable and then you don't have to
worry about spoilage but converting
those very highly automated
manufacturing facilities and bottling
plants from one to the other really is
not a thing and that comes back to your
earlier point about hey how how screwed
up is the system that you can't do
everything they just those types of
changes are years in the making
require a lot of capital and a lot of
thought because it's just a smaller
market yeah we saw this with toilet
paper I mean you know it would seem that
when the toilet paper demand went down
in office spaces and gross
and uh restaurants etc you know public
retail locations there was this idea
like okay well then just package it and
bring it to CVS and to Walmart and to
all of those places but you're talking
about different role sizes do you know
it shipped in pallets rather than in
neat plastic wrappers I mean these are
not trivial changes that have to be made
right and you just touched on
distribution changes so Cintas or if
you're gonna go serve our factory we get
a truck that brings in our our uniforms
and our some paper products for the
bathrooms and yeah they come in big
rolls that same truck still has to make
those stops so it's not easy to say oh
and now we're gonna go stop at the
locals all the CVS's or Duane Reade's
around and then CVS and Duane Reade has
to say okay where am I gonna put this
stuff like these things take up more
room on the shelf how am I gonna price
it how am I gonna merchandise it will
customers buy it there's all of those
questions need to get answered and yeah
it's it's different it was a little
surprising for me personally the paper
goods weren't able to just you know a
buyer at CVS can just say okay we want
that but then it still comes it back to
supply that all the stuff that's cut
wrapped and made for an office building
you can't go into the building and just
get it and resell it right and if it's
in the warehouse it's like well that's
still a big change how are you gonna go
deliver it so when it comes to so I want
to get to the fragility of the system
bigger picture but before we do that
there were news reports about potato
farmers at some point during the
pandemic just dumping potatoes in the
trash essentially saying there's no
demand that the potatoes so the potato
is not as perishable as milk right I
mean why I was having trouble
understanding why that was going on and
I think they were citing low Restaurant
demand and I get that the supply chains
don't totally interact but with
something as less perishable it would
seem that you can find a better option
throwing the potatoes in the trash so
you know the peril of the American
farmer is not overstated
it's an existence that's incredibly
difficult and incredibly reliant on a
lot of external factors just completely
beyond their control it's all compiled
sort of go through a brief comparison of
how milk where prices are explosively
high right now
yeah and potatoes and some produce where
it might be really low so for milk
you've got cheese ice cream fluid milk
those are just call those are three big
categories well food service cheese and
food service milk have all certain food
service ice cream is smaller but still
there have all taken a hit but the
retail demand arguably has eclipsed tip
in addition to that so hey you're in
your house you're gonna eat more ice
cream cuz you want to spoil yourself
you're gonna have when you make a
sandwich you put two slices of cheese on
a sandwich instead of a small one at a
subway and more people are eating cereal
than they were before kids are at home
or you know those things have kind of
brought demand back up and there's
government purchases which creates even
more artificial demand so supply is low
right now
farmers culled some of their herds
summer hot temperatures cows don't make
as much milk supply is low demand is
bigger than supply prices go up sure
potatoes how if you took away McDonald's
or fast food for lunch how many people
would eat a potato product like french
fries at lunch right the use of a potato
is almost exclude I don't say
exclusively but predominantly food
service and so it's not something that's
easily converted to a retail behavior so
you're not gonna make it you're not
gonna home make your own french fries
you might bake a potato
occasionally but probably not everything
you own every day and you know as much
as brands like orida and the frozen
processors see optics in demand it's
just not enough to offset the loss of a
McDonald's Burger King you know how many
how many restaurants or drive-throughs
have french fries all of them right and
if that even goes down by 10 percent it
hurts potato farmers demand it goes down
by 40 or 50 or 80 percent they're toast
and then despite it being relatively
stable the procced it's art of a supply
chain impact so if McDonald's isn't
buying the company that makes their
fries is saying well okay I don't need
potatoes the profit and they're probably
a processor themselves and they say to
the farmers got I don't want it I don't
want to pay to store it I don't want to
pay to hold it I don't want to clean it
my demand is zero I don't need it and
when you get a lot of companies like
that coming together it just it's bad
news for the farmers that's how you end
up that's how you end up with potatoes
in the trash
yeah because for them the cost of
picking it cleaning it getting it ready
is it cost right it's cheaper just to
say I'm gonna let it rot in the field
yep so one of the things that seems to
have been exposed by all this is that
just-in-time supply chains are arguably
more cost-effective in the short and
medium term when things are sort of
normal but they're quite fragile when
when the system is disrupted right I
mean that's the takeaway that I'm
looking at I don't know if you would
agree or disagree or or build on that
there's pros and cons this is a crisis
unlike any we've faced in a long long
time if ever right so it's hard to sort
of castigate corporate America or
businessmen for relying on best
practices that worked really well until
they didn't
the fragility of just-in-time inventory
is clearly evident now and I think this
crisis will change some of the
operational behavior and supply chain
inventory process management where hey
we need to yes it might cost a little
more but there's a an operational term
called safety stock you know you always
keep 10% of your monthly inventory turn
in your warehouse just in case safety
stocks will go up investments will be
made to quickly convert and change
product lines right I think there's
probably going to be less product
proliferation there won't be nine
flavors of goldfish crackers hmm there
will be the three big ones because at
least there will be an efficient
changeable process to go from well we
have regular cheddar and to others and
we could always convert the two others
into regular cheddar at a drop of a hat
right things like that this that would
be how I see it playing out in the
future so in terms of just the cheese
and how you're sort of managing things
and talked a little bit about you you
guys don't have a crazy number of
flavors as an example and it seems like
that was a decision that predated
coronavirus in any case I mean talk a
little bit about what you're doing and
how your distribution works yeah so we
you know I'd rather be lucky than good
and we built our brand on Amazon from
the very beginning we were sort of a
disrupter to the system that the two big
competitors we came in against were they
had private equity sugar daddies they
had big marketing budgets and were
established in retail and we decided to
kind of go where they weren't and
decided hey we're gonna launch this
online and see what happens and we can
get grassroots support and that's how
we'll grow and that's what we did and
because of that we have an extreme
good ecommerce infrastructure in place
so we've been able to handle big surges
in demand online that hey on the very
beginning of kovat people were panicked
buying we didn't have any stock outs
right and we were able you know the team
knew what to make we have basically
three main SKUs that look we can crank
out a lot in no time and then on the
retail side you know we we also do
just-in-time inventory from a cash flow
management standpoint and we've been
able to be agile enough to keep up that
you know hey when we need overtime we
use overtime we make sure workers are
safe and healthy every we have I feel
unfortunately I feel safer going into my
factory than I do going into the grocery
store hmm because I trust our sanitation
procedures and rules more than just a
random stranger so we've we've adapted
by kind of doing what we have been doing
but a little faster and a little better
that hey ecommerce retail starting to
pick up and you know what knocking on
wood every day that business is fine and
under the circumstances the fact that
it's not a cataclysmic disaster puts me
in the winner's circle for sure right
that's that's been my exact thinking the
fact that we're not experiencing a
cataclysmic disaster in our business I
have to be grateful for at at this point
in time you can check out the just the
cheese products using the URL down in
the video description we've been
speaking with David sharp man who's the
owner and general manager of just the
cheese and is very graciously offering
our audience 20% off just the cheese
products when you use not only the URL
but also the coupon code down in the
video description david so informative
and I just really really enjoyed
speaking to you today pleasure having to
it